i'm raymond arroyo this is the ingram
angle
and now america's birthday gloom or
glory
this year there seems to be a determined
effort to hijack or
dismiss independence day it is an effort
that we as a people should resist
the president's having a party for first
responders in the military at the white
house this weekend
which is a nice gesture but listen to
his vision
for july 4th by july the 4th there's a
good
chance you your families and friends
will be able to get together in your
backyard or in your neighborhood
and have a cookout where we not only
mark our independence as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus
did our independence ever hinge on the
spread or containment of a virus
i mean we still have our liberties those
were given by god not dr
fauci now the democratic national
committee is continuing this
independence from covet theme in a new
ad
and this year there's more to celebrate
the freedom to hug a grandchild to come
back together again
uh people hugged their grandchildren and
got together last year
remember the july 4th celebrations at
mount rushmore
i was there i covered it and at the
white house see all those people
and that was when operation warp speed
was still underway reducing july 4th to
a campaign ad
or vaccine victory lap diminishes the
importance of this holiday
when we need it most july 4th reminds us
of our hard-won liberties
and it marks our independence as a
people from a tyrannical overlord
historically the british beyond cookouts
and mattress sales
john adams wrote a letter to his wife on
july 3 1776
clearly explaining his vision of july
4th
it ought to be commemorated adams wrote
as the day
of deliverance by solemn acts of
devotion to god almighty
it ought to be solemnized with pomp and
parade with
shows games sports guns bells bonfires
and illuminations
from one end of this continent to the
other i'm well aware of the toil and
blood and treasure
that it will cost us to maintain this
declaration
and support and defend these states yet
through all the gloom i can see the rays
of
ravishing light and glory
what has become of those rays of
ravishing light and glory
adams would choke on a hot dog if he saw
how cavalierly americans brush
off their birthright a new fox news poll
finds that
only 69 percent of americans now believe
the u.s
is the best country in the world to live
in just six years ago it was 83 percent
the numbers are even worse among those
under 45. the big question is why
part of the answer lies in the
intentional
racial division and the trashing of
america's past
last year people took to the streets
literally destroying
the markers of our shared history
statues of
lincoln the great emancipator grant
columbus
even the saints who founded the missions
in california will rip down
the visual memory of these great
american lives once a source of unity
and pride
have been physically stricken from
public places
now in classrooms and in the pop culture
all memory of these lives are being
replaced
or reimagined young people are taught
that america is an irredeemable place
predicated on the sin of slavery and
colonization
which continues to this day
stuffed with deformed history and
lukewarm marxism
the acolytes dutifully repeat their
catechism
you believe in a book that was rewritten
by man by a white supremacist man at
that
this book says respect thy neighbor as
thy own unless they are a woman
black trans pregnant in that case stone
them to death
republicans blocking critical race
theory want to continue
miseducating our kids all in the name of
patriotism
my four girl just came up to me and
asked if she could play with my dumbo
trump flag
this one
and i feel like it's kind of profound
did he ruin the flag for anybody else
just me if someone were defaming your
relatives your grandparents
you'd be mad as hell and that's what's
happening here
this is not a sober reckoning with
american history
but the strafing of it we owe our
children the whole truth
good bad and ugly now to add asininity
to injury
a task force at your national archives
of all places
has a new report that the rotunda which
houses the declaration of independence
and the u.s constitution is itself an
example of structural racism
why you ask because the rotunda quote
lauds
wealthy white men in the nation's
founding while marginalizing black
indigenous and other people of color
women and other communities
but the task force has a solution they
would like to reimagine
the rotunda put in place trigger
warnings
content advisories to forewarn audiences
and i'm quoting
of content that may cause intense
physiological
and psychological symptoms you house
historic documents and records
this is not the release of song of the
south on disney plus
we don't need a warning additionally
they recommend
the creation of safe spaces at every
national archives facility
thomas jefferson may need one of those
safe spaces as well as the other
founding fathers
can we still use the term founding
fathers at the federal reserve you can't
they recently instructed employees to
embrace bias-free
language avoiding constructions like
founding fathers
man-made and those bothersome personal
pronouns
whatever the intentions all of this
divides it divides people by sex race
religion we don't even agree on a common
language anymore the consequences of
this were dramatized
vividly by the sad spectacle of olympic
contender gwen berry
last week she made a big show of
disrespecting the flag of the country
she competed to represent
not only did she ignore the anthem she
threw a t-shirt over her head in protest
but this is gwen berry in 2015
the first time she qualified for the
olympics she had no problem
waving her flag and representing her
country then
what happened between 2015 and 2021
clearly gwen berry like many others were
repeatedly told about
the gloom of america focusing on her
problems and setbacks and
sins but like the people who make up
america that's not all there is we are a
good
inventive and loving people and this
july 4th
let's rekindle john adams rays of
ravishing light
and glory and celebrate them despite our
differences
as one american people